this is the most evil character in all
of One Piece you may think it's one of
the world Nobles who can enslave and
kill whoever they want while having
absolute protection from the Marines but
you'll be shocked to learn that this
character is much worse than them it's
also not doflamingo who took over the
entire nation and made all of his
enemies into mindless slaves and it's
not even oroshi who allied with the evil
pirate kaido and turned wano into a
wasteland where people literally die of
hunger you may be surprised to learn
that the most evil character in one
piece is not even a pirate which makes
him more evil than even Blackbeard who
freed the world's most dangerous
criminals from prison and hodie Jones
who wanted to kill every single human in
the world the most evil character in one
piece is actually the former government
scientist Caesar Clown who was secretly
kidnapping small children and drugging
them in his sick experiments so we can
now say without a doubt that